everything we've talked about so far
with this you know startup company
selling socks and all that has been
raising money from an equity we raised
private money we when the company was
private it went to vcs and it went to
and it went to
angel investors and you know maybe you
could go to your your friends and family
to raise money and then the company
could go public and raise money from the
public markets but there's actually two
ways that a company can raise capital so
raise capital so this is why this
playlist is called capital markets or
it's part of it the name of
raise capital
capital is just essentially i mean the
easy way to think about it is you're
raising cash to put that you want to
invest in some way to grow your business
or to sustain your business or start
your business so everything we talked
about about so far was equity
and that's a sell essentially selling
shares in your company to raise money
right and so that's all of those vc
examples
and the equity investor so when you sell
equity you're essentially selling you
know you're kind of making that person
who's buying the stock you know an
equity is the same thing as stock
you're making the person who's buying a
stock kind of a partner in the company
so if the company let's say there's two
situated if the company goes bankrupt
and i'll talk a lot more about what
bankruptcy even means
but if the company goes bankrupt all the
shareholders end up with nothing they
end up with nil right but if the stock
if the company
has a lot of upside the stock gets a lot
of upside right because they're they're
they're partners in it if if this was a
company you know that startup that we
talked about if it turns into amazon.com
and becomes a billion dollar company
everyone is going to do really well
everyone's going to share in that upside
but there's another way to raise money
and actually this is probably something
that's more familiar to to kind of at
the household level i mean at the
household level you never raise equity
you never say you know what uh well you
can but you're not going to say hey i
need to buy a house
why don't i go to my rich friend and
offer to sell him 10
of the stake in my house to him and you
know and and he'll be kind of a partner
in my house that could happen but for
the most part it doesn't usually when
you do something on a personal level you
raise money through debt
through debt
and that's interesting so debt
debt what's good about debt is it's so
let's think about it from the from the
point of view of the person who's
lending the money to you right
that is just borrowing money
borrowing money
borrowing money and this is you know i
think all of us know what borrowing
money is
i go to my my rich friend and i say hey
you know could i borrow a dollar and
i'll give you a dollar 25 in a year and
he says okay you know you're good for it
but i'm essentially promising i'm going
to give the money back at some future
date if i sell equity i'm not promising
anything i'm like hey i got a great
business why don't you give a dollar and
then you get a 20 cut up my business if
my business does awesome you get twenty
percent of all of the profits of my
business if my business does horrible
when you took a risk you get nothing and
i get nothing that says you know what
even regardless of how my business does
if it does awesome all you're gonna get
is the interest
so
all you get is interest that's kind of
the upside so the upside's limited right
if if i borrow money at nine percent
interest all that person is going to get
is nine percent even if my company
becomes the next google or or um you
know or microsoft or whatever else that
person's just gonna get nine percent on
their money while this person might have
gotten you know a hundred times their
money because they made a bet on the
other hand this downside is much lower
so limited downside
because they're going to get their money
back at a certain you know there's a
certain payment schedule
and they're going to get their money
back before the stockholders so let's
say in a situation where the company's
going to difficulty and we'll do a whole
playlist on bankruptcy the people who
lend money to the company will see their
money before the stockholders see
anything so how does all of this come
out from the balance sheet so let's say
we have a public company and this is
really you know if you wonder what a cfo
at a company does this is really the
main decision that they're always making
do we raise money well how do we raise
money if we need it and we raise money
from the equity markets or from the debt
markets so let's come up with a company
again
let's say that that's its current assets
not current i don't want to say current
assets it's
the
the assets that it currently has current
assets mean something different and
we'll talk about that in the future
but let's say
so that's its assets i'll just assets
you know it might have some cash here
some cash and we'll go into more detail
we'll actually look at real company
balance sheets and decipher what all of
the terms of the balance sheet mean but
that's its assets for now and let's say
right now it's all of its money it's
raised so far have been from
has have been equity unless it's a
publicly listed company it doesn't have
to be
but let's say
that's all of its equity and let's say
it has
let's say it has i don't know 10 million
shares
10 million shares
and the other interesting thing about
when a company is public remember every
time when a company was private and it
took an investor when it took equity
investors they had to sit and have a
negotiation saying what is this worth
right what are these assets worth but
what's cool is is when you have a
publicly traded company
these shares are traded on an exchange
right these shares are on an you know
let's say it's on the new york stock
exchange
new york stock exchange so every day you
could go to yahoo finance or wherever
you know and and you can look at a chart
let me draw a chart
you could draw a chart let me
so let's say
so and we've all seen stock charts i
think so let's say that this is you know
this could have been his ipo date or it
could just be the start that we're
looking at let's say the stock right
after the ipo went up and then you know
the whole market went down a little bit
but the stock you know maybe it's it's
there right but on any given really
almost any given second
there's a price that somebody traded
that stock at and it might not be the
best price but it is a price and we'll
talk about why that happens right
because you might have 10 million shares
and if only i don't know 100 shares get
traded at any at any second or let's say
only 100 shares get traded in the day is
that an indicative price because that's
not a huge percentage of all of the
shares but anyway we'll talk more about
about what volume means relative to the
total float and all of that
but let's say at this split second the
company's shares traded at 15 a share
this is 15 right
at this second in time this was like
right now traded at 15 a share and you
could look it up on on your bloomberg
terminal or whatever else so essentially
the market is providing us a value for
this company the market is saying wow
you know
the market is willing to trade the share
at 15 there was a willing buyer and a
willing seller exactly fifteen dollars a
share
so that means that the market at that
moment is valuing this company at
fifteen dollars per share times ten
million shares
so fifteen
dollars per share
times 10 million shares that's not a
dollar sign
10 million shares
so the market is assigning a 15 times 10
is 100
150 million dollar
market cap
market capitalization capitalization
for the company and when you hear and
you know you can look on the kind of i
think it's the key statistics tab on
yahoo finance and you'll see market
capitalization for company and it's just
the number of shares times the number of
shares times the price of the shares and
this is essentially what the the
market's value
of the equity is the market is saying
that this piece right here
is worth 150 million dollars and since
we have since this piece is the same
size as the assets we have nothing else
on the right hand side the market's
essentially saying that the assets right
now are worth 150 million dollars and
these aren't always going to be equal
we'll see in the probably in a few
videos when you start raising debt you
have to do a little bit an extra
calculation to figure out what the asset
value or and i'll throw out a new term
here the enterprise value of the firm is
and the enterprise value is essentially
the asset value minus minus kind of
excess cash cash the company really
doesn't need to operate and we'll we'll
go into more detail of that but we'll
just view it as the assets for now so if
i'm the cfo of this company and let's
say we need to raise another
i don't know 15 million dollars i have
two options right i could say okay the
company is trading at
fifteen dollars per share i need to
raise 15 million dollars so why don't i
i could issue another million shares and
do not it wouldn't be an initial public
offering because i'm already public it
would be a follow-on offering or
sometimes it's called a secondary
offering although this word secondary
has kind of two connotations but it
would be a follow-on offering where i
would you know i would issue i'd go to
the board we would essentially create
another million shares and then sell
them into the markets and hopefully
people will buy it at 15 a share or
probably a little bit less because we're
kind of flooding the market with a ton
of shares maybe they buy it at 14 per
share and we would raise
14 million dollars
and that would be a follow-on offering
and so we can you always use the public
markets as a way to raise more money we
didn't have to go to all this i mean for
the most part we didn't have to do this
huge valuation exercise in negotiations
and do another um and do all of this you
know higher banks and all that although
the banks will still collect fees we
actually would have to hire banks to do
this but anyway so that's one option or
the other option is you know we're an
established company we're generating
cash we could make interest payments if
we want to we could go to a bank and
actually there's a lot of different ways
to do this but we could essentially
borrow money and let's say we do that
instead of doing this let's say we do
both so let's say we did a million
dollar follow on offering that gave us
14 million dollars
let's say we want another
2 million dollars but this time instead
of selling shares so right now how many
shares do we have we sold a million we
had 10 million we have 11 million shares
11 million shares let's say you know
what like our let's say as a cfo i
feel like our shares are going to move
up a lot more so we don't like selling
them at these at this low price instead
and let's say interest rates are really
low instead we're going to borrow money
and that's essentially raising debt
so let's say we borrow
another three million dollars because we
need it
so this is so actually this would be
debt three million dollars of debt three
million and we would get
three million dollars of cash
three million
three million of cash and so now our
assets are all of this stuff
our assets are all of this stuff on the
left-hand side
and what are our liabilities now now we
didn't have liabilities before because
everything we had were equities but now
we do now we owe somebody
three million dollars right here and
i'll talk more about all the different
ways to kind of borrow money but it's
essentially it could just literally be a
bank loan it might have just gone to
bank of america and said hey we're a big
company and you know we're good for the
money why don't you lend us three
million dollars and you know maybe it
would be three million dollars at you
know low interest rate at maybe six
percent per year
and bank of america feels good because
you have a high we'll talk more about
credit ratings and all of that but they
say oh you know you have essentially a
good
company credit score and so we'll give
it to you low interest rate and so what
happens in the future is these assets
are going to generate hopefully some
cash and before these guys see it before
let me do it in
before these equity holders this is the
equity holders right now before the
equity holders see anything these guys
have to get paid their interest and
we'll we'll i'll show you all of that on
a line by line basis in an income
statement everything we've done so far
has been a balance sheet
but something interesting is happening
now now all of a sudden your assets
which is that side i know i just keep
writing over the same drawing your
assets are now larger than your equity
right and i think now and this is just
kind of a review of the balance sheet
video you see
that the assets
are equal to
your equity
which is this right here
plus
your liabilities your liabilities now
are three million dollars right
plus liabilities
so if you wanted to know what your
assets are worth right so your assets
are equal to your equity
so what's your market value of your
equity the market value of your equity
well we figured that out already we have
11 million shares now and let's say
let's say the stock plummets to 10 a
share for some strange reason or for not
strange reason so what's the market cap
ten dollars a share eleven million
shares
we have a hundred and ten million market
cap
and we're doing a market value and we'll
talk more about the difference between
market and book value but this is the
market value of your equity and then
what is your liabilities well we owe
three million dollars right so plus
three million
so we could say that for the most part
the market value of our assets the
market thinks that this entire left hand
side
that this entire left hand side
is going to be worth the value of our
equity the market cap of the company
plus the amount of debt which is equal
to 113 million dollars
right
so 100 the value of these assets are 113
million dollars and that for the most
part is your the enterprise value of the
company what is the company
the company's assets worth and we'll
talk there's a little bit of a of a
tweak we'll do in the future on on
enterprise value but that's essentially
what the how how you kind of kind of can
value what the company is worth a lot of
people when they do a market
capitalization calculation they say oh
that's what the company is worth well no
that's what the equity is worth market
cap is what the equity is worth if you
want to know what the company is worth
you have to take the market cap and then
add the debt
right another way well i won't go too
complicated because i i know i've just
realized i run out of time again see you
in the next video